[Applause]
everyone knows that i'm a huge animal
lover
if they know me and our pets are part of
our family
and so i saw this headline about a 17
year old
carly deary and her mission to keep our
furry friends our families
safe in an emergency and i had to meet
her
and carly joins us now carly
how hello are you
i'm good how are you oh my gosh speaking
of just
beautiful and incredible
carly you have raised over two
thousand dollars to create oxygen masks
for pets in this time in this crisis
where so many things are happening
what made you think of this idea how did
it come about what is your story i'm so
obsessed with it
my dad actually inspired me to do this
he is a des moines fireman
and he was recently called out on a
house fire and there is a puppy inside
almost gone and he was able to
resuscitate the dog using
a pet oxygen mask and within 15 minutes
the dog was just running around all
happy and excited
and i just think that there's not really
a lot of awareness that these masks even
exist
so my mom and i we started making dog
treats
and we put up flyers in exchange for
donations and then my dad and i set up a
gofundme page to raise money for these
masks
and i was able to raise about twenty
three hundred dollars
and then we purchased 49 oxygen mask
kits and those were distributed over
eight different fire departments in the
des moines area
i mean i can't even
believe our hearts bleed for these pets
these pets are
our family we i don't even know how this
was in a bigger conversation
and you are my light bulb an aha moment
to this revelation
and you're the voice for these pets and
you are the one putting it into action
and keeping them safe and you are a true
hero
and carly the people at paw print oxygen
were so excited to hear about your story
that they're donating
ten thousand dollars worth of
oxygen mask and rescue kits to your car
oh my gosh that's amazing they're a
small company whose founders aren't much
older than you
because you're all young game changers
saving the world and
teaching us how it's done may we keep in
touch with you and find out what you
guys are doing with your
like you know appropriating these masks
and just everything that you're doing we
want to keep in touch please
awesome thank you so much for having me
thank you carly
[Music]